germany is saying goodbye to nuclear
power reactors representing almost half
the country's nuclear capacity are due
to be shut down by the end of this year
the remainder will be switched off
during the course of 2022. it could be
seen as the worst possible time to do it
with europe battling an energy crisis
but the big switch-off is being met with
glee from anti-atomic activists
[Music]
these protesters are making their voices
heard and have been doing so for decades
outside a nuclear power plant in
northern germany
for over 35 years now activists have
been meeting up once a month to call for
the reactor to be shut down
today is the 425th meeting and the final
time that they'll be here braving the
elements that's because the brocktof
nuclear power plant one of the most
controversial in germany will be
decommissioned at the end of the year
for pastor and protest co-founder hans
kuntavana it's a day of mixed feelings
it is mainly a sense of relief that the
nuclear power plant is finally history
we never imagined back then that we'd
have to hold out for so long
the 2011 fukushima nuclear disaster
prompted germany to declare a nuclear
phase-out by the end of 2022
but many countries continue to rely on
nuclear power
this promotional film made by the french
nuclear industry depicts it as clean and
above all climate friendly a line of
argument also favored by the country's
president
to achieve our objectives in particular
carbon neutrality by 2050 we will for
the first time in decades relaunch the
construction of nuclear reactors in our
country
greenhouse gas emissions are lower than
those from fossil fuels but compared to
wind or solar power nuclear energy
production is far more expensive it's
really clear those countries around the
world that are most intensely committed
to civil nuclear power
are
either countries with nuclear weapons or
countries really demonstrably keen on
nuclear weapons the reactor will be shut
down but the radioactive waste will
remain in storage there for decades to
come there's still no permanent disposal
site anywhere in the world which is why
the activists plan to continue their
fight
[Music]
well to understand what the nuclear
phase out means for germany let's just
take a look at the country's energy mix
so in 2020 renewable energy sources like
wind solar biomass and hydro had
increased to make up 43.8 percent of
germany's power but coal is actually the
second most important source lignite and
hard coal supply almost a quarter of
germany's electricity the german
government is though aiming to close all
of its coal plants by 2038 as it reduces
carbon emissions next up gas-fired power
stations provide 16.1 of germany's
electricity
in 2020 then we come to nuclear power
plants which generated
11.3
but that is obviously about to change
with all of germany's reactors due to be
switched off by the end of 2022.
now the world is watching germany's
energy transition as it aims to switch
off sources currently providing almost
40 percent of its electricity that's
nuclear and coal
critics say that soon
that it could be too soon uh to
and uh could even lead to blackouts
especially when it's dark and there are
no wind blowing no winds blowing and
there is no sun they suggest that
keeping nuclear power plants running as
a stable source of energy is the best
thing to do
well let's discuss this a little bit
further with michael schneider who is
lead author of the world nuclear
industry status report and an opponent
of nuclear power thank you very much for
taking the time to join us on dw
business and what do you say to that
suggestion that this is
with europe suffering an energy crunch
the worst possible time to be turning
off energy sources
well you know i mean the the german
nuclear pays out has been in the making
for a long time
uh it's in decades that the german
society has been discussing the issue
uh by the way the the term like energy
vendor which now has been integrated
into the the english language like
energy transition dates from 1980
and you know as soon as 1986
when the
chernobyl uh disaster started happened
uh took place
they were and germany had actually
published in germany there were 20
nuclear phase out scenarios published so
there's a long exercise of
thinking and designing
this this nuclear phase out so what is
happening now is
is just a consequence of these latest
decisions that are now 10 years old so
there was a long period of preparation
for that and
let's face it it's it's been a
phenomenal uh investment security you
you can you know imagine you can invest
into other
electricity generating technologies
knowing that 4 000 megawatts will switch
off by the end of the year that's a
phenomenal
investment security that doesn't exist
in the same way in other countries but
something we do need to bear in mind
when we talk about when
when we talk about the switch off of the
nuclear power is the environmental
impact and the fact that germany's
renewable sources aren't quite ready to
make up for what's going to be lacking
from the the nuclear switch-off uh is
this actually a bad move for the
environment given the nuclear given that
germany will be using coal to make up
that loss
no that's that's the myth and that's the
problem you know
the the the the reduction in nuclear
outbid
output over the past 10 years has been
compensated for twice over
by the increase in renewable energy
sources so
it's it's a myth that that actually that
has last led to more coal no it's
actually it will in the coming years
it is accepted that it will mean there
is more coal and lignite being burnt to
make up for the loss of nuclear power
over the next few years because wind and
sun are not ready to fill that gap
no it's actually
not true i mean there is a very clear
pathway now in order to
double up the speed of implementation of
renewable energy sources and
in fact the new coalition has a target
for
2030 to to phase out a coal uh
differently from what was said earlier
so to bring it further uh closer to uh
now
originally it was 2038
and have by 2030 80 percent of
renewables in the electricity mix so
in fact what we have in europe is that
especially france is is worried about
the nuclear phase out because uh germany
and belgium the two nuclear phase-out
countries have actually
saved uh the the french grid uh in in uh
the last week when uh that thermometer
dropped below below zero so
we actually have a quite unique
situation where nuclear france is
depending on the
the nuclear phase-out countries in order
to stabilize its grid
we do have this unusual situation don't
we in europe where we have germany on
one hand phasing out and france if
anything wanting there to be more
nuclear power plants across europe why
do we have that
enormous difference
well you see in france there has been
always the the the a myth of lagoon
nation you know that that france can
only be
as powerful and as radiating in the
world with nuclear weapons and with
nuclear power and
and frankly france has always used the
nuclear technology whether on the
military side on the civil side as
geopolitical tool so
don't forget there is now a presidential
election coming up
france has taken over the presidency in
the european union at first of january
so there's alliance buildings so again
once again
france uses nuclear power as a
geopolitical tool
so
but on the other hand don't forget that
the new nuclear power plants that the
president has been talking about
uh we're talking of a grid connection
between 2040 and 2050. so which is
sort of a bit late for the environment
and it's a bit late for
uh you know changing the the situation
in terms of our generating sources well
thank you very much for your time
michael schneider i do appreciate you uh
giving us so much of it that's michael
schneider from the world nuclear
industry status report on dw business